welcome to the course I'm Lauren I'm a
course developer here at Udacity and I
have a background in experimental
psychology and I'm Ronnie I'm a program
manager at Google I run a global program
called launch bed to help startups
launch high quality apps my background
is in startup marketing and I love
mentoring startups on how to think
marketing from day one and this is what
we're going to learn in this course
marketing helps you understand your user
focus your product on your user needs
and take your product to market but this
isn't going to be a marketing 101 class
this is more of an applied marketing
course yeah we set up this course to
mimic what you will go through when
creating launching it iterating on your
own marketing plan now the lessons in
this course are divided into different
stages like the understanding stage the
prepare stage launch iterate and scale
so tell us more about that
we'll start by understanding the market
we play in or the users how we're going
to segment them how we're going to
position our product in one competition
and what's our value proposition then
we'll prefer everything Netta towards
the launch from a marketing plan all the
way to landing pages and cover the
launch itself including PR and how to
grow your user base from 1 to 1,000 then
we'll learn how to scale with paid
advertising and free growth hacking tips
and finally how to iterate and keep
improving your product and marketing
based on your measurements and analytics
but marketing is so much more than just
advertising in social media it's about
truly understanding the market how to
best build your product and how to
understand your customers and their
needs and where you fit with the
industry in this first lesson will cover
market segmentation competition and
value proposition by the end of this
lesson you'll have a better
understanding of your users and where
you fit in the market based on things
like your variable position and
competitive analysis so let's dive into
the understanding part of marketing